and one of my all-time favorites a dish
that always creates a stir is the daddy
of all brunches
steak sandwiches
[Music]
for me the secret of a great brunch is
fun and casual fuss-free cooking and
everyone helping themselves
this is the ultimate steak sandwich
you want the rolls royce of beef
it has to be fillet now season it
beautifully
i like to open up
the top of the peppermill to increase
the size of the pepper in the steak so
it gives that bit of heat
nice little chunks
you just roll now
nicely all the way around
now slice the garlic
in half
pan nice and hot
olive oil in
hold the steak and just place it into
the pan don't drop it at the front of
the pan
we're going to tilt the pan forward to
cook the back of the steak dual purpose
now roll it back
and sear underneath
next
my garlic
and roast that garlic
thyme
fry that time i want to hear it we're
not looking for a lot of color because
you're going to dry out the fill it so
just
one
end
turn it back down
and steer the other end in
lift up your time place it on top of the
garlic
there
lift up your fillet
and sit there on
top
of your garlic
butter in
take a spoon
tilt the pan gently
lift up
and baste
i've got that scented garlic
thyme flavor
the steak is going to cook evenly
because it's sat on a little
a little bed
in the oven for 8 to 10 minutes
[Music]
pan on
for the relish you think of a steak
sandwich you think of a sort of nice
heated tomato relish
to make the relish finely dice a red
onion three finger rule one in front
two behind
through
and chop
wow
next roughly chop a chilli keeping the
seeds in for extra heat start off with
the olive oil into a pan
onions
chili
[Music]
generous with the olive oil
i want a nice sort of rich
silky relish
from there
take your tomatoes you can't just use
red tomatoes but these yellow
and red make the perfect combination
now put your salt in
cut them
and then
roast those tomatoes off
take a wooden spoon and just sort of
break them up
once the skins blister
the whole tomato just starts to release
all that really nice sweet
texture
a little teaspoon of cherry vinegar
gives that nice acidic balance the
sweetness
of the tomatoes turn down the gas and
just let them sort of stew perfectly
now a steak sandwich would not be
complete unless it had the most amazing
mustard mayonnaise
simply add three tablespoons of
mayonnaise to three teaspoons of whole
grain mustard
[Music]
now i've got the reddish almost down to
like a really nice jam
now
i want to make that relish a little bit
more fragrant
some basil
slice it through
sprinkle that basil in there
[Music]
beautiful
look at this
there she is
my crown jewels
time to take it out
smell
is incredible
just baste one more time
to fill it
the touch is quite soft in the center so
it's just coming up to mid-rare let it
rest the same time you cooked it it'll
be nice and pink evenly throughout the
steak
to make my sandwich i'm going to char
grill some sliced chipatta bread season
it nicely
just a little drizzle of olive oil i
want to get that bread nice and crispy
pan nice and hot
bread
in
push it down
smell is amazing that char sort of
charcoal flavour once you've got those
marks on the bread it just stops the
bread from becoming soggy and look at
this here
it is
stunning
on
slice it
gently
one beautiful slice
wow
it's nice and pink all the way through
and the beef is so soft
it's almost like slicing through butter
let the knife do the work
take
a little bit of mayonnaise spread that
the back of the spoon
on both sides
next
lettuce
take that beautiful slice of beef
and then relish
on top of that beef and just slice the
sandwich in half
beautiful
now that's what i call
a steak sandwich
trust me serve the sublime sandwich for
brunch and you'll put a smile on
everyone's face
[Music]
my next easy standby supper is beef
meatball sandwich with melting
mozzarella and tomato salsa
[Music]
top a lightly toasted roll with
pan-fried meatballs then tear off chunks
of creamy buffalo mozzarella pile it on
and melt it under the grill
for the tangy salsa slice sweet red
onion then add juicy diced tomatoes and
roughly chop fresh coriander
season and drizzle with olive oil
spoon over
[Music]
perfect in a flash beef meatball
sandwich with melting mozzarella and a
tomato salsa a sandwich to die for
[Music]
melting my lunch when i was growing up
was very plain
pretty trashy but i still love it now
and again fish fingers with a delicious
chip butty
the secret
of a good chip butty
is in the potato
now these are desiree
potatoes one of my first ever jobs
was working in a chip shop i used to put
sacks and sacks of potatoes into the
rumbler which was then the potato peeler
all day long today i'm going to do
something a little bit healthier
for my oven chips with a twist
simply peel
slice and blanch for three to four
minutes
drain
season
and cover well with propeca
spread evenly over an oiled baking tray
and place into a preheated oven for 20
minutes
simple as that
next up easy fish fingers
this is pollock
a really nice firm delicious
fish
got the fish in finger size batons of
fish put them onto your plate and just
lightly salt them you can do that
literally 20 minutes 30 minutes before
you start cooking the fish
it firms the fish up beautifully
and it allows it to become a little more
durable especially in the pan now for
the coating start by thoroughly coating
the fish in seasoned flour
and then just roll it
to get rid of those little sharp corners
because then it stops those corners
almost burning in the pan
in
to your egg wash
and really coat them
wonderful
and then this is dill
goes brilliantly well with a fish
and run the dill through my breadcrumbs
that makes it more aromatic
lay them
onto your breadcrumbs
nothing wrong with the chip butty
nothing wrong with fish fingers
just give it a lovely modern twist
beautiful once the fish fingers are
thoroughly coated they're ready to pan
fry
and they'll need around three minutes on
each side
i want the fish fingers to be nice and
crispy get a really nice color on them
first and then we'll flip them over
and finish them with butter
bring the heat up into the pan
and a nice
little knob of butter
that'll work wonders with the
breadcrumbs and the dill
nice and carefully
take them out
they look and smell incredible
stay nice and crispy
now to assemble my chip butty starting
with buttered thick crusty bread
get a slice of bread
mop up that amazing flavor
on
slice in half never slice in an angle
my mouth is salivating beautiful
on with the ship butti there's one thing
missing
and it signifies that i've never
forgotten the joy i've come for food but
my god that makes me feel like a
nine-year-old
excuse me for a moment when you
want to stuff my face
[Applause]
[Music]
homemade fish fingers and my ultimate
chip buddy so simple to make but trust
me it tastes amazing
[Music]
this is a picnic sandwich with a twist
but the secret is in the layers
i'm gonna make a delicious tapenade a
puree of olives seasoned with capers and
anchovies a nice tablespoon of extra
virgin olive oil
garlic in
a little teaspoon of red wine vinegar
that just sort of zaps up the flavor
quite like leaving it nice and chunky
tastes better and feels richer
i much prefer spreading a smooth layer
of tapenade rather than using butter
now to prepare my first mediterranean
sandwich filling
i want nice long
slices
of courgette because yes can be a bland
vegetable
season them nicely
once that grill's nice and hot a
tablespoon of olive oil
the more color you put on those
courgettes the more flavor
while my griddle courgette's cool i can
prepare the bread this is a stunning
beautiful country loaf but we're not
gonna slice it i'm just gonna cut the
top off because i'm assembling a picnic
sandwich basket
and then an inch from the crust and go
around
scoop out a nice large hollow
don't waste this bread put that out to
dry it makes the most amazing bread
crumbs
the secret now is filling that cavity
with all those wonderful mediterranean
flavors i'm going to leave them to sort
of sit and marinate lightly season the
inside of the loaf
drizzle
of olive oil
line with that wonderful tapenade and
spread it generously
puts the groundwork in
starts to set the tone for the flavors
that we're incorporating
traditionally the main protein in
pambanya would be tuna i'm sticking with
the med but replacing the fish with some
of my family's italian favorites
palmer
i'll start lining my sandwich from the
center
every time i add another ingredient it's
just another stunning layer of texture
and flavor but what i'm thinking about
is what actually complements
the next layer mozzarella
a little spoon of my tapenade
we've got the most amazing tequila
pepper so we've got a nice smoky
barbecue flavor open them up and lay
them
on top next layer these wonderful
grilled
courgettes
on top of that
some blush tomatoes
concentrated but really chewy and
delicious and each time lightly press
them down
creamy mozzarella again
and then finally peppers
push that down not too firm
fold in
and seal that with your tapenade
almost like a little glue
now lid on
to seal
all that flavor in there
and not only travels well but actually
tastes delicious
that is one stunning
picnic sandwich
next a brilliant picnic salad that's
just as robust as your pan bun yeah
carrots and cumin and orange perfect
combination again travels brilliantly
it doesn't wilt
it doesn't disintegrate
orange zest
[Music]
squeeze
the orange over
sunflower seeds a bit of crunch in there
pumpkin seeds again
another bite
next a hint of spice toasted cumin seeds
ground with the help of a little coarse
sea salt
a nice fine powder
now for the dressing tablespoon of dijon
mustard tablespoon of honey
half a tablespoon
of white wine vinegar and then a nice
glug
of olive oil
fresh mint
and coriander
the minute you start picking fresh herbs
all that flavor comes out a nice mix
vinaigrette mix that in
give enough dressing
bind it together excite the palette not
drown it
if it was a leaf salad then i'd take the
dressing separately but because this is
a robust
root vegetable they can sustain
being dressed now
and eaten in two hours time
sweet spicy
fragrant
can't really ask much more from a carrot
can you
beautiful
[Music]
just when your guests think that you're
cutting up a delicious
country loaf
[Music]
look at that baby wow
and who would not want to join you on a
picnic with a sandwich like that
my ultimate picnic lunch to surprise and
impress panbania bursting with rich
sunshine flavors and serve with a
refreshingly zingy carrot cumin and
orange salad
[Music]